[Music]
hey I'm late for work
leave one other hey where'd you fall in
the drawer seriously yes is that I had
them over last money see the entire day
[Music]
hey sugar you don't wanna can you take
up a trough yes sir okay um to the
milliner all right oh man he can't be
all of his foot by and watch will you go
in a timeless
it sounds like and it feels like you
just push me I didn't know that I was
commenting I take it you don't know
better
bugling you'll give me the whole damsel
battery by the way you do think to my
body I was 17 I think just a little here
will do the trick
and another line here for symmetry and
we talked about the dart line to your
right
oh yeah and the cheeks yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hey want to play a curl sure let's go
kid you ready yeah I think I'm ready I'm
about to school you I'd like for you try
how do you ever been beaten by a girl
before
I never been beaten period good glad to
be the first this is going to be so
embarrassing for you should we call your
mom why pick you up when you start
crying you know what I almost feel bad
for you me why it must be hard to be
beaten by someone half your age
you ready I was born ready
[Music]